hey edgar
today is not your day today's my day
yeah
ciao
italiano
today i am in italy and we're gonna try
out every single snack italian snack
and with martia's recommendation
yeah
let's go edgar wants to play
it's okay it's not your day anymore it's
my day i get to pick whatever i want
yeah
he's so cute okay you get one thing
let's go
so we're driving in the volvo but we're
in italy you've guessed correct i drove
all the way
all the way from uk
just for this video so we can eat snacks
let's go our first destination eurospar
andiamo let's go
[Applause]
whoa
that's so cool we're looking for the
snacks where are the snacks oh i found
the snacks here's the italian snacks you
love them right
are you in heaven right now i might say
so happy i never seen her smile so much
this video has just become us buying
groceries what is that we need to get
the snacks what are you doing
what paradiso should i get those
oh what why they what i wanted one
[Music]
all right
wow
we found it this is it
but no this is tea what is this flauti
you want floating that looks good
i'll get a floaty
tutto
oh this looks good
this looks good
farsi cow
is that you had that that one has a
smile on it though i think i'll go with
this one
fiesta classic
i try these you like old people stuff
this is what old people eat
my grandma gets you those and you're
like oh thanks thanks a lot grandma got
me something light one time who drinks
something like grandma i don't drink fun
delight i think real fun though you know
what i wouldn't even pick fanta to begin
with are we is that it no there's gotta
be more they got nicky bro
no they don't
there's no connective bra
what's the point
we should go back we're driving back to
sweden now
marsha's picking more stuff so i'm
picking potato chips i know she loves
these
these are huge
oh and these are big too i see these at
airports tomato flavor really what's
wrong with italy
i'll try
it
166 that's not too bad i think we got
way more than we need so we're not going
to go anywhere else right okay let's go
back
benvenuti we are back
look at all the snacks wow uh it
actually looks way less in in the camera
i don't know it looks more in person
right
yeah yeah
so we have a bunch of stuff
marzia has asked me to tell you that
some of it is she doesn't actually like
she just bought it because it's italian
i just picked some random stuff that
looked gross like
[Music]
that looks nasty right can you see it
this is old people oh it's uh what are
those called passion fruit fico
[Music]
ficus
fig that's right
big
should we start with cookies then
all right starting with the famous
oh this is barilla
barilla
[Music]
they smell nice
and this is granny cookies but i like
them i like them
oh welcome
oh good
seven out of ten next up tener reset
marta picked these those are my favorite
martial's favorite
[Applause]
does this mean if i don't like them it's
over
we'll see
[Applause]
and they smell good they smell weird
smell that
smell that guy
oh the whole clock
they got little gooey stuff inside
they're good
they're better than them
they're better yeah
fine you win eight out of ten they're
they're pretty damn good
[Music]
i bought these because i recognized them
but apparently martial is not a big fan
i've actually eaten these because we had
them and i like didn't finish it so i
already know
they're oh they're doing like this weird
um is whatever made milk
nah
they're actually pretty good these are
the best
just so
this is my best to say
it is she's not lying
i don't know
they're saying three of these equals one
pair in terms of calories that's pretty
good
right
they're trying to say that
it's better to eat cookies than fruit
i don't believe that yeah
seven out of ten next up canestrellini
i feel like that has too many words in
it canestrelli that's what it should be
called
canisterlini no it's callously needed
so you were
wrong
[Applause]
these are
500 calories
[Applause]
i'm granny cookie i'm not
they're too dry they're too dry
you like it
could eat the whole box you could eat
the whole thing
i like the thing on the top what is that
bad name too dry but pretty tasty
so far the winner is the lemon ones
where do i need them six six
all right moving on to the weird flouty
i waited for flauti
so in italy for those who don't know you
don't eat breakfast in italy you just
eat like this this is right
yeah no but everyone does
no and it was the same when we drove
through friends it's so difficult to
find like food they're like no no this
is food
listen if i could eat these every day
for breakfast i would all right not
everyone has crazy metabolism
what's that for me all right
that's pretty good
kind of makes me a little sad like this
is the only time i'll only i don't eat
sweets
that's good
i don't know is it good i'll tell you
based on the calorie
124 calories but there's so much fat
you it
five five no six six
oh she made what was that face you hate
it i like that that's a maya like the
milk one not the chocolate oh yeah
that's the face maya makes when she
hates something
moving on to the fiesta classic so when
would i eat these just a classic
this is like the british british
equivalent of tea and crumpets
these are also 160 calories
here we go
[Music]
i don't know if the mic will pick up on
your weird stem
it's got a
i was the orange orange flavor yeah
that's way better than the other one
it's a little clumsy to eat though since
it's all covered in chocolate so
definitely a minus point for that but
the fact that it's crispy or charred
soft inside
it's not hard i like it's a bit
overpowering taste with the orange i
don't know if i would even finish this
to be honest
[Music]
that's a fun what do you mean
me
we're married
are those your favorite no
but it's orange
works
we are so different
look at this they got eyes on them
that's funny
oh it's so soft come on look how soft
you like soft stuff touch it
i feel like i could fit the entire thing
[Music]
they kind of taste like the most generic
thing ever
five five you gave me my other one
yes i did i didn't get the other five
yeah
i'm already full man
all right moving on to the potato chips
yeah
i
potato chip my weakness okay that's what
i like i'm a potato chip kind of guy
cookie
not worth the calories bro which one
should i try first oh i forgot i don't
want to eat more sweets
well they're like twix right they're
twix
come on
what's the most generic thing ever
[Music]
well i'm sure if you grew up with him
sure
what's incredible about him
i fought four the three lowest ones of
ours
you upset
they're bad what do you want me to say
all right i forgot the priorities some
how do i open these
these looks good because you keep them
in the fridge which i like
oh they look pretty oh oh look at these
oh and you fold they thought about this
that's a strong egg
all right strong egg i think i would
have liked it got kind of stuck in my
mouth
you like
yeah
you like that
that's probably the best one of the best
one yeah yeah
that's my favorite thing out of
everything that's the thing i get out of
all this
all right
it's so lemony
no lemon though
is it flavor then milk
oh my god so many
see this i think would be more up my
alley yeah
so when would you eat one of these
when would you eat this
[Music]
that one's so much better
no
all the gooeyness spews out when you
and then
i don't
know i don't like him do i like anything
i don't know probably not
poor yeah
you know what because he gave me that
face three
that was gross that's legit that's bad
you got bad taste
the other one is
[Music]
when you put it that way yeah i can see
why it's like frustrating you know
yeah if anyone talks just about my
stellar chips
you're going down all right
chips can i eat chips now i really want
to eat cheddar
oh tomato flakes chips
tomato chips
really italy tomato chips you made
tomato chips do you eat this do you want
this
[Music]
smells like a tomato
this is the most italian thing why would
you how much do you like tomato
try
you
of course you like it
[Music]
oh yeah i've tried those there's my
ketchup flavor yeah it smells like
tastes like ketchup
i know what you mean
that's not a good thing you i'm hoping i
find like my ultimate snack here like
this is
what is this
you bought these what are these
[Music]
do you think you're the only country
with a crinkle cup
[Music]
whoa they're huge
good crunch very salt salty
nah not good
poor
dixie oh yeah we were screaming in the
store where's alexey
in vodka
oh
it melts in your mouth
oh okay
it comes in these little mini box things
dixie let me see the commercial dixie
[Music]
does it have a slogan
no
official partner with the nba
they do melt in your mouth that's good
i like that what flavor is it cheese
[Music]
that's the best chip so far
which you know doesn't say much
but i would eat this again for sure
very good job
eight eight dixie kids there look at
this
it's like a sharing package have you
seen this before
what is this
here here
you don't need a bowl
[Applause]
come on that doesn't even work right
all right
these are really nice actually they
remind me of land chips and we have in
sweden this is what a chip supposed to
be what do you mean you bet try it
oh my god
you will die if you say that
these are really good
mm-hmm
this is what i want like it seems like
fresh potatoes chips they keep the peel
they they keep them
yeah peel on them
they're thin
they're heavily fried
mmm
i don't like pringles you know what i'll
say it [ __ ] pringles
i'm not a fan of bringing them this is
what i work
well i can't eat everything out i can't
eat everything
[Music]
that's a nine oh god dang it
i missed one i have to eat this i don't
want them i'll eat them last
oh
what is this
[ __ ] oh croc canyon paquita
[Applause]
does that look similar
no
they're cute cute sizes
[Music]
i think i had these before they're very
corny
[Applause]
riccioli di mice what does that mean
what
yeah it's corn
i don't
they taste like tortilla chips
but softer and less
yeah softer tortilla chip
and saltier
why would i eat this
why would i eat this in my own
relationship
i'm just saying
these are like the most american snack
ever amica snack is that america amica
i never had a meal then
what's the flavor it's pizza flavor
i don't see it but it goes to pizza
oh with pizza flavor
why would you do this
how could you do this
i kind of like it
now that i know it's pizza flavor
yeah these are good
eight hmm pizza player
they're good
these yeah
big time nine they just went up
who is that pizza flavor
i bought it as a joke these are the best
ones
all right to watch down we have estate i
love us attempt since the last time we
were in italy i
so good
like eight years ago or whatever
and it's zero which i like
well that's still good that's really
good we should get more
10.
that's really good
how could we forget the fonzies
i love these
this one
you did good mark sam
i love funsies
they're really crunchy they're not fried
tastes like cheesy
they leave the rest of you on your
finger so like you lick them afterwards
big fan love fonts love the fonts you
got to try the phones
right
that's a solid that's a 10. yeah
only 10. that's this is the one thing we
agree on
now fonzies are really good
but i've eaten these for so long i don't
know if you brainwashed me
okay
moving on to candy sweden has the best
candy i will
this dude gonna fail hard
like
what is this
this is your equivalent of candy oh you
look so excited i'm going to destroy you
it's all yellow in here what do you mean
obviously
no
no this is not ken
you're so old
what
you can't tell me then
i don't know how long it takes can i
have lunch here
haven't had it in like so long
has anything exploded in your mouth yet
[Music]
what was that something in my mouth
they don't fold me
there's
oh you like the phone if you post your
phone
no
absolutely not
zero
[Music]
no
this is my
licorice you have a lot of licorice to
choose from it's without gelatin
nice
oh these smell good
[Music]
yeah
as someone who loves in liquorice
if i was like really desperate for it i
would get these they're not grab sorry
i will have another one though
yeah they're pretty good that's it
in sweden we have less goodies so you
can pick like your own favorite kind of
candy i i've only seen that once here in
italy and all the candy was like old and
gross
sorry these are
oh they're coffee
i thought they would be a coca-cola
flavor
i didn't they didn't click they're quite
very good
they taste so much like cafe latte and
not just coffee no
actually spitting it out no
i feel like when people watch these
videos they want like someone going oh
my god so good
for me i'm just like
i'm sorry i'm being honest i don't like
you
you also like anything i should also say
according to marcia that i don't like
anything
which is true
i pride myself in that now
these
oh my god
yeah
yeah my great grandma
holy [ __ ] are they these the fudge ones
[Music]
oh my god
yeah granny god bless her
she would always have no idea
it's hard
it's not fun how hungry
oh what
what's with old people candy i don't get
it
wow i can see it being like nice and
reminiscent but would i buy and eat
these
i am so
no
zero
you disappointed me you set me up
thinking it was my grindiest credit
thing and it isn't
[Music]
yes
another hard candy
who likes hard candy no one likes hard
candy hard licorice i could eat but
that's where nah come on hard candy
i have it it's a nice flavor
it's milky this feels like a christmas
uh kind of thing right
it's lemony
oh
it's gooey like
a little bit more good than i bargained
for
stop it's not chocolaty inside no it's
not
what is it
i'm like that evil
guy from ratatouille
if i don't like it i don't swallow what
that's what she's saying
that's the line they should have used in
ratatouille
this looks good
so kinder is one of those companies that
might say i thought was italian and she
kept bragging about it
it is to tell you oh never mind
how tiny
two
i'm joking
i look so disappointed
that was okay seven
yeah white chocolate huh
what kind of sociopath eats white
chocolate i might say that mine's in
dave actually that's why exactly
[Music]
yeah that's pretty good
okay now that's an eight that's pretty
good
ah it went down to seven
one more okay these are the ones marks i
said were kind of nasty
[Music]
is that what you said with nasty
[Applause]
[Music]
oh dark chocolate right
i like dark chocolate
it looks like a nipple
[Music]
uh three i didn't like it sorry
this is marza's favorite chewing gum out
of all time cinnamon brooklyn
wait they're american
[Music]
oh they smell amazing it smells like
cinnamon
[Music]
i realized martin
we are completely different people
what the hell is this
we had similar to these i think we call
them
yeah that's the same go
each other you can blow the bubbles with
i'm so bad
no way what do you mean no way
[Music]
zera terrible okay
that was all of them i will now pick my
very favorites
and the winners are
was the clear pattern i like i told you
i like potato chips i don't like cookies
yeah it's here it's here
don't worry
the best potato chips
is probably these
but i probably realistically eat these
the pizza
[Music]
these are the winner
who would have thought
pizza flavor was the best well if i had
to pick one winner the fonzie wins sorry
sponsored win
ponzi used to mashed potato
that i say is the best cookie
paradiso is the best soft snack
and these are still trash but they're
better than all the other ones so there
you go
i've eaten every single italian snack
yeah every
thank you for watching smash like
subscribe for more see you next time